[Music]  good morning  [Music]  my husband  this is great look out your window no  I'm taking you away for the weekend I  just can't believe this was my life that  I get to live with you  measures her  that meant nothing to me before you Anna  Gray's office we wanted to welcome the  new fiction editor I bought it for us I  should have asked you first  oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo  the architect this location is perfect  I'm going to build you a fabulous house  please stop speaking of my husband as if  I weren't here and you may call me mrs.  gray I'll pick you up a fire I may not  be done by then  cuz we  we're being followed  how the hell are you Anna  Jack what do you want  so you wanna play yes sir right  I made a vow to love you faithfully  forsaking all others did you sleep with  her to comfort you in times of need and  to keep you safe first long as we both  shall live  Tirzah bye